take it away
great we would like a volunteer and we
believe we have someone who is
enthusiastically offered yep
uh so we would prefer you not to look at
the computer screen okay um and just
stand uh
yeah the audience would be great try not
to disconnect the wire okay
we apologize this is still very much a
prototype i'm glad you picked rondo's
these fit me better
same
yeah
um and this may take a moment to plug it
in oh yes
now
[Laughter]
um right so as you can tell um this game
is meant to be played without any visual
input in fact um
do you hear this is the game view
for those that aren't super familiar and
this is our scene view because we wanted
you to see what was going on
yep so what the phone would show
okay so wait just a moment
uh you should be i'm gonna just check
um hold on
space forward okay great you're you're
calibrated so i turned off the screen so
you can see what uh
our play tester is looking at well
facing towards facing towards so yes so
our play testers here's a hay over here
in this game you move using a head tilt
so you tilt your head forward or down to
move forward
you tilt your head backwards to move
backwards
and this is the player so the tl dot is
the player and you can turn to face like
the sound source and tilt your head down
to
move towards the sound source if you hit
a wall you'll go bonk
we still have to work out the balances
between all the sounds
backwards tilt your head back yep
is the over here spatialized uh yes
right yes so behind me how do i go
backwards uh tilt your head back oh i
get it oh no not that way
i like the footsteps yes so um
too far
it's asking me what i'm doing
what are you doing okay this is really
hard all right congratulations you found
the first one now there's another one
marker
oh great yeah so um someone else want to
try oh keep going keep going for a
little longer i'm going i'm doing
something else now yeah you're gonna try
to find the target again
so this is actually our calibration
level
the calibration level is really useful
for giving a frame of reference for
distances and how far what the what the
sound is and how it sounds further away
yep
um
yeah so
maybe try
find one more target and we can move to
the
next
level
what is going on
okay well
that happens sometimes
no not too far too far
i can tell it's over here but i don't
know how to get there if you if you
because the
you can you can turn yourself by the way
you can like rotate
and like you will now face that right
it might be that the sound source is
very close to a wall
that's true
yeah well we don't want to take up too
much time for my presentation
it no
we anticipated people to have
difficulties here do you want to take a
look at what the what the game looks
like
so you're the teal player first one was
here and then it moved up here
and it went across here yeah oh it moves
it did move
surprise okay
yeah um great and uh we actually want to
showcase one more level this time i'll
put it on put the glasses on because
it's uh unless do you want to try it
nobody's very good at it by the way when
they when they start out but people do
get used to it yes um as
oh i'm bonking into a wall fun times so
we also want to showcase a little bit of
level two
maybe
so you've had people go through this
yes people yeah do they do they
recognize the sound behind them versus
in front of them okay
so this is one of the points we're going
to bring up before it's very difficult
to tell in front or behind but as you
move you can hear whether you're getting
closer or further away okay is that done
with louder or is that done with some
other sound
oh that's done right so we actually were
wanting to do something where in when
you're facing it it actually gets a
little bit louder so you know you're
looking in the correct direction
right now that's not
uh very dynamic
yeah i'm having technical difficulties
we'll show off level two later
um
well it's it's we have a different
roll-off but we're just using what was
what unity afforded us
unity plus bose ar so
um as you noticed later on like you can
turn yourself and then move right yes
okay thank you all for being here this
is our presentation for going in blind
i'm gwen edgar and this is my teammate
rio levine
and welcome so first we're gonna start
you off with a background on blind
gaming right so actually
blind gaming has been around basically
since video gaming was a thing and when
i'm talking about blind gaming i mean
like electronic gaming um so starting in
the 70s atari came out with this game
called touch me and it had flashing
lights and it made noises so it was
actually accessible to people who
couldn't see
also
all of these text-based role-playing
games were
getting popular and if you had a
text-to-speech software
a visually impaired player could play
those as well but console games action
games were very limited
but
gamers are going to game
so
blind gamers played video games anyway
so they could use text text-to-speech
and just based off of sound cues
navigate through very complex levels
completing games like so 2d punch out
super mario 64. a blind gamer has even
completed ocarina of time if you've ever
played that game it's crazy
without visuals
even resident evil 4 was accidentally
accessible because if you pressed pause
your character would reorient themselves
to face towards the goal
that they were trying to get to
fighting games like 2d fighting games
are actually pretty accessible because
they have binaural sound you can tell
which side your opponent is on
so mortal kombat street fighter
both pretty accessible and blind players
have even been known to play
uh first person shooters so
as long as there are enough sound cues
it seems like
blind players can play these games and
that brings us to
our audio only platformer which as you
can see
you see nothing
[Laughter]
you have you have to use uh only audio
cues to navigate throughout the space
because it's using a lot of binaural
inputs so you're able to tell in what
direction different things are
as you all know we're using the bose
glasses for this project
and there are a couple of gestures that
are automatically integrated such as
nodding your head shaking your head and
double tapping
uh we were exploring uh these different
things and so first we're trying to do
movement with head nods so step step
step step
and we found this got really tiring
and it's hard to know like were you
taking a small step were you taking a
big step how far am i going like how do
i get through these different types of
movements
so we decided to look at something else
which as you saw you tilt your head down
to move forward if you're looking this
way you go this way you tilt your head
back to go back and this allowed for a
certain smoothness of walking and the
step foot you hear footsteps as you like
move forward which gives a sense of you
being in the place and a sense of that
movement that you're playing towards
and as you like you turn your head your
direction will change you might have
seen a couple of times that there was a
curve happening because of
motions like this
so so that brings us back
to the bose glasses we were using the
gyroscopes a lot which meant we couldn't
use the head nod or shake because they
were kind of using the same thing and if
you're trying to move forward you can't
do this
now then those were the sensors so that
left us with one thing the double tap
now what does any platformer need
well gwen i think it needs platforms
exactly what do you need for platforms
jumping
so we decided to move that double tap
towards jumping and so we you know we
were thinking about okay so we're going
to double tap to jump but we want to
follow follow the platform but if we're
looking at a platform up here we might
start walking backwards if we're looking
at a platform down here we might start
walking forwards so you're thinking all
right all right we'll have a jump mode
so you double tap first you enter jump
mode and then you don't move around so
you can like look at all your targets
and not worry about falling over an edge
or going out of the zone
but this got really confusing
we had it such that three tap three
missed jumps you'd exit it wasn't
integrated very well it didn't feel very
smooth it was kind of clunky
people were like why did i stop moving
[Laughter]
so i decided to move away from that
instead
just
jumped and what what this really meant
was that we could only design levels in
certain ways that
looking at the platforms would be within
your range of motion without trying to
go outside of it anyway like moving
along with the jumping though even even
more was that if we just tried to apply
a force the player could go spiraling
off into space because they didn't know
that there wasn't something for them to
land on
if we allowed them to jump at any point
they might like jump onto a wall and
then like fall or go through the wall or
fall down and they don't know why
they failed
so instead what we did is we allowed
jumping onto platform so if you're
looking at a platform you just jump and
it's all good and if you don't it's like
nope
and doesn't let you yes
and we found that worked pretty well and
it didn't upset players it was very
important to us yes
um so okay we've gone over what you can
do within our game here are some of the
challenge we face challenges we've faced
when
developing it so far
first challenge player orientation
fortunately it worked right off the bat
when we did our demo that's good but in
general uh if you just start the game
without doing any kind of calibration
you're looking in some random direction
so you need to make sure to like
face the player forward and since the
last time we gave this presentation we
found a method that faces you forward
towards the the z-axis
but there's no way to face and make the
default any other direction which is
fine we just built all of our levels
along the positive z-axis
yep
next challenge
properties of audio sources and the
placements where we put them this was
discussed in some of those lectures and
in some of the psychoacoustics lectures
that we're talking about but yes forward
and behind you can't really
differentiate so if you're on a platform
and there's something moving behind you
there's some platform moving in front of
you you can't really follow either
platform because there's the you can't
focus on either source they get very
muddled in your head if it's not clear
the platforms are making sound yes i'm
sorry i forgot to mention that the
platforms make sound so you can follow
them so you know you'll get on the
platform we turn the volume down on that
platform or else it's just overpowering
when you leave it we turn it off such
that you can always detect what's in
front of you
and that works really well because the
audio that is like moving with you
doesn't bother at all with the um
with the other moving sources so if
you're on a platform it can still make
its noise and you can follow one in
front of you
yes and ambient noise also is fine to
use
but also as discussed you can tell some
things left or right and you're able to
turn towards those yep
limited inputs we were talking about
this earlier um in a lot of games you
have keyboards so you can have like
special abilities and different modes
you can enter in a bunch of like menus
and whatnot and with this we had the two
and so we were working a lot with those
and that was just one of the challenges
we faced
yep
um uh also as you might have noticed uh
your method of movement is imprecise you
don't know where you're going you're not
really sure if you're going straight
forward you don't know where exactly how
far things are away from you you might
think you're going forward but your head
is tilted the side of it so you're
actually going in this direction
fun thing problems to think about one of
the first things with this was the
platforms because players had a lot of
trouble looking exactly where the
platform was
we had to make a huge collider so this
entire green box if you hit if you are
gazing anywhere inside of it you'll go
to the platform on your jump yes
it was almost impossible to hit this
even when looking at the screen
yes
um and in graphic games it's also
lenient because you jump and you can
like fall onto it you don't have to jump
exactly to where it is
so it follows and to help with the
imprecise like i think i'm moving
forward but maybe i'm listening to the
left or right
we made it so that if you are going fast
enough and you're within like 15 degrees
of forward you will go straight forward
on the z axis this made one of our
levels which was essentially a very long
hallway much more
much less frustrating i won't say easier
but less frustrating for players because
then they could be like oh i'm actually
going forward
um as mentioned don't use different
heights so uh
right like
yes so as players were playing more and
more they were able to tell they were
able to learn more about the sound and
tell where it was but when you're
starting the play
it's really difficult to try to detect
where anything is in this axis and i
think that based on our play test many
players were like in a kind of restful
position when trying to follow it
which meant that
they couldn't see anything above them
first of all because restful is
apparently tilted down a little bit and
not looking forward
uh
and also that
uh
i'm sorry that the we couldn't build
levels upwards right now so we're trying
to build them straight more straight
forward so the players were able to jump
back and forth
um
so
play tests yeah
so on monday i got 11 players to play
test the game on
wednesday i got one more player to play
test um
based on some of the feedback we got and
oh by the way
everyone said that it was an interesting
experience and some of them even said it
was fun
a lot of them did say it was fun um
so that's good yeah so one of the first
things that popped up a lot was distance
detection or radar so you have no idea
how close you are to the wall you
experience that or you don't know how
close or far something might be we're
thinking of adding something like
perhaps you could have something like a
cane tapping and like you'll hear
different noises or oh there's a gap
here and we could take away barriers
around edges with the something like
this or something like rear assist
parking so as you like get close to wall
goes
yep
frame of reference oh yeah so the first
level went through a couple of
iterations in our most recent iteration
you have to find multiple targets before
you progress to the next level and this
is to give the player a chance to really
like
get more in the game understand this is
the target this is the sound the target
makes this is how i locate that sound
this is how i move forward and moving
backwards is also an option
the target after after the one that you
saw was directly behind
so the idea was trying to give players
that range of motion
and the noises was i listening to more
than one target at the time no no okay
target voices
that was just one target it was one
target yes the target would spawn after
the next one was destroyed that last one
was destroyed
yep
uh
yeah so front or behind versus left to
right
um
damage death and other punishments
so you know we talked about like players
spiraling into the void after they jump
uh what do you do when a player dies you
put them at the the beginning of the
level right
well
this is confusing because players don't
really know why they failed they know
where they are now yeah because now
you've just moved them without them like
moving themselves so they've completely
lost
where they are so we decided to take out
damage and dying and
all of that
we have a level with obstacles in it if
you hit the obstacle you say ouch you
get pushed back a little bit and this
doesn't disorient players if players are
worried about dying they're much more
afraid to like move and explore their
world as well so we took that out
level complexity
um as i mentioned during the play tests
uh players were saying that as as they
were going through they're getting
better at navigating they're feeling
more confident and they're getting more
used to the sounds they were hearing uh
so they're able to detect different
noises better and the patterns so we're
wondering how far we can go with this if
we have people that know how to play the
game how many levels of complexity can
we add can we have a staircase of
platforms can we make it so you need to
navigate almost kind of platforms almost
like a maze what can we do with this can
we have enemies how many enemies what
kind of things can be used uh so the
idea is really how complex can these end
up being made this was not something
that we could follow in the scope of
this class but that we would like be
very interested in pursuing and on
average it took players about 10 minutes
to get through all of the levels that we
had the three levels we only saw the
first one in this round but there's a
level with a platform and a long hallway
with swinging blades
yep
yes
and last level guidelines these are we
have three main level guidelines that we
want that we take as our contributions
and we want to give to you as main
takeaways from our project
the first one being to offer the player
one audio target at a time that can be
trying to navigate looking for a source
that can be trying to jump on the
platform that can be trying to find the
swinging blade
after you have gotten past that you can
present a new target as long as the old
one has been removed
second
always have a linear and flat path to
follow at least especially in the
beginning because you can't really
detect when something is above or below
you especially if you haven't heard the
sound before
so especially with these beginning
levels make sure things are just
in front of the player so this doesn't
mean that you can only move forward in a
level but it means you need to have a
linear progression path so you can like
you can go backwards you can move around
but if you've used an element that needs
to go away or else be specifically re
specifically brought back for reuse
yep
oh
and third give clear and immediate
feedback when you're looking at
something you're able to see
oh i missed the platformer oh i got hit
by something or oh i didn't make the
jump or oh i ran to a wall but if you
don't have that immediate feedback here
people are just like what happened i
it doesn't sound like anything happened
or oh things sound further away now they
don't have a good orientation point so
footsteps when you're actually walking
the nope when you can't jump the bump
against the wall when you hit it we're
very clear and good ways to give that
feedback
and okay well that's our presentation
it's our game going in blind yes
[Applause]
you